the single most powerful force for
adolescent mental health is strong
relationships with caring adults
adolescence has always been a difficult
phase of life but today's teenagers are
navigating a world that is vastly
different from that of their parents
teens are experiencing a mental health
crisis according to a new CDC survey 42
percent of high school students reported
feeling persistent sadness or
hopelessness 31 percent of girls and
young women have symptoms of anxiety in
the decade before the pandemic we were
seeing Rising rates of anxiety and
depression and then of course the
pandemic did not help
so how do we equip teens emotionally
with the tools they need to navigate our
complex and ever-changing World well
here to help us answer this question is
psychologists and CBS News contributor
Lisa Lisa is a Yale educated
psychotherapist with a doctorate in
Clinical Psychology from the University
of Michigan who specializes in education
and Child Development she is the author
of three New York Times bestsellers
untangled under pressure and the
emotional lives of teenagers the latter
being the subject of today's exchange
curiosity plus empathy or just empathy
is I would say overwhelmingly the most
effective and also wanted response when
teenagers come our way with their
distress today we explore the issues
that are most pressing for today's teens
we talk about the impact of social media
mental health the pressure to succeed
academically and professionally and the
struggles that come trying to fit in and
find a sense of belonging but most
importantly Lisa provides concrete
actionable strategies for supporting
teens who feel the mercy of their
emotions so they can become more
psychologically aware and more skilled
at managing their feelings and and how
to approach friction at home
before we dive in though this episode is
brought to you today by Roca I get asked
fairly consistently about the glasses
that you see me wearing on the show well
the answer is Roca specifically these
are the Hamilton frames I love them
they're super high performance very
light great Optics and they offer tons
of great Styles but the main thing is
they never ever slip off my face ever
and I'll be sharing a bit more about
Roka later but with that please enjoy me
and Lisa D'Amour
well Lisa it's an absolute Delight to
have you back on the podcast the first
time you were on was in April of 2019 so
a lot has happened in everybody's lives
uh especially in the lives of our our
precious teenagers
um and so you are here today to expound
upon how we can better understand our
teens and guide them parent them through
what has been a very difficult period
and what is a very challenging period
period for teens you know throughout the
history of human beings right but there
does seem to have been something rather
acute and different about the last
couple years that we weathered and you
know your book uh has been an amazing
resource to me as somebody who's
parenting an older teen and a younger
teen at the moment and it's that thing
where just when you think you've got it
figured out something happens and you
feel completely at a loss to how to you
know start of manage the situation and
so the book has been a real TouchDown
for me and a great service to many
people I'm sure so thank you for writing
it thank you for saying that and in
getting kind of ready to to talk to you
today I came across the uh
the the New York Times review of your
book the first sentence of which I just
have to read out loud the very first
sentence of the review goes like this
you know what's enjoyable about living
with teenagers nothing truly not one
thing they might distract you by
appearing to be deeply interesting and
funny but don't be fooled teenagers are
diabolical you might have a different
lens on that but I think that that's a
very kind of common parental reaction
that that that kind of spawns from
confusion perhaps that like what is
going on with these creatures who at one
moment not too long ago were quite sweet
and now suddenly you know seem to be you
know people we don't recognize anymore
yeah yeah no it um
it has never been easy to be a teenager
or to raise a teenager and you know one
of the kind of broad ways we can walk up
to it is to recognize that one of our
Cardinal rules in Psychology is that
change equals stress
and I think about if you put a 12 year
old next to an 18 year old right you're
not even looking at the same species
anymore
and that is so much change in an
unbelievably short span of time there's
no way it's not going to be stressful
for the kid who's going through it and
for everyone around them
and and with that I mean we can kind of
intellectualize that and understand that
uh but in the the Heat of the Moment
when things tend to get a little chaotic
we default to you know patterns or or
behaviors that are you know by and large
not helpful well-intentioned but not
helpful
so how do we even you know sort of
Embark upon you know understanding this
I mean I would say just at the outset
um as somebody who you know I my teen
years were fraught a lot of people's
teen years were fraught
um and you know as a parent as I
mentioned I've got you know two teens
now and I've got two older stepsons who
are 26 and 27. so I've been doing this
for a while and you know I at times I
feel like I've learned a lot and I
really understand this and then other
times I'm completely out of my depth but
one thing that I have developed is just
a huge compassion for teenagers it's
just it's so hard and of course the last
few years have been uniquely extreme and
uh
and you know every time I feel like I
have a grip on it uh you know something
happens in the degree of difficulty
escalates and I you know I just don't
know what to do and I find myself
misstepping constantly and then trying
to figure out how to repair whatever
misstep that I made
um so I think it's it's you know
disorienting for for most parents so how
do we begin to kind of understand like
just in a in the most General sense what
is happening with the onset of
um adolescents as our younger people
enter those teen years I mean one of the
things that was striking about your book
is the Neurology of of it all and how it
actually begins quite earlier than we
might suspect yeah so when psychologists
say teenager and the onset of
adolescents we have always marked that
at age 11.
which is much much earlier than people
tend to think people think 13 you got
till 13 teenager and we got time
and truly papers going back a hundred
years we've marked the onset of
adolescents at 11 and the reason for
that is puberty is underway and
sometimes it's visible outwardly and
even if it's not visible outwardly it's
certainly underway internally and that
does change the brain that change
changes how it operates that changes the
balance of power in the brain power is
increasingly distributed to the
emotional centers
and the experience in the home is that
the kid who literally yesterday would
let you call them cutie patootie wanted
to go to the store with you thought your
jokes were funny I think for a lot of
parents it feels like overnight the door
closes
literally to their room they bristle at
childhood nicknames they don't think our
jokes are funny and
um it's very very hard not to feel both
shocked by it because it happens so much
sooner than is expected
and also very hard for it to not feel
personal and and I would say
that if I had to describe my work it
really is in the space between parent
and teenager and a huge amount of what
my work aims to do is to give the adults
who care for teenagers a perspective on
adolescent development
that makes it clear that adolescence is
not something they do to us
it's a really really challenging phase
that they are working their way through
and we're often pulled in in ways that
don't always make sense or that we don't
feel comfortable with right
I think we understand that individuation
is a healthy thing and this is a
necessary aspect of of of of growing up
and healthy in in the best way and yet
it still does feel personal even when
you know that it isn't and so the
challenge like the Jedi approach is to
de-personalize everything and not allow
any of this to kind of you know impact
your emotional you know kind of state of
being so that you're not reactive in
these situations and to have that Gap
that moment where you can be like okay I
can identify what this is it actually
doesn't have anything to do with me
yeah
if you can do that twenty percent of the
time you're killing it I think I think
that so often it goes so fast and is so
powerful I there's a section in my book
called why your teen hates how you chew
and and it's about separation and
individuation and
I remember having learned about these
things in school you know this was part
of my training and then having my older
daughter turn 13 and start to move into
that phase where no matter what I did it
absolutely rubbed her the wrong way and
I remember thinking oh my gosh like the
term does not do justice to how hard
this is how hard it is that when I do
things that are like how she sees
herself becoming it's annoying to her
when I do things that are unlike how she
sees herself becoming it's annoying to
her everything is annoying to her and I
think that part of what helps us to
sustain people through those moments
with your kid that are just they're
painful right like you're just in it is
to really
um I hope have some if you feel heard in
that you feel like okay someone gets it
that this is a really hard thing with my
kid or even
you know that common thing that happens
where a kid comes home from school and
you're like how was school and it's like
nothing but complaining like that is so
much often what happens
I think there's real value in kids being
able to come home and dump all the
garbage of the day
but I also think that my work is to say
to parents this is not the most fun part
of the day like this is this is often
like not the conversation we want to
have or at best sometimes just really
tedious but being present for it is
really valuable to our kids not trying
to give them advice if they don't want
it is valuable for our kids
I think that um
when parents know they're not in it
alone that this thing that feels so
specific and personal that's happening
in their home is actually happening
everywhere I think that's where I can
try to communicate that information to
parents in the hope that then when it's
happening it does to feel does feel a
little less personal or more diffused
right a mantra that I've that I've sort
of used to help me through those moments
is
is understanding that that it's my job
to love my kids but it's not my kids job
to love me you know and not looking to
my kids to have any of my needs met and
I think that's a common misstep I mean I
was parented by somebody who who in a in
a not so healthy way like parented me
and my sister in a way that you know
what was Paramount was making sure that
her needs were met and so that's part of
the my like framework and and DNA like
those are the buttons that are installed
and if I'm not careful I will default to
you know that type of behavior that I so
loathed right like everything I've done
to try to overcome those patterns and
and not parent in that way in a weak
moment I will I will do just that very
thing
so you're self-aware
which
is as good as we as much as we can hope
for it's not always enough though that's
the self-awareness will get you is good
but it's a good person it's got to
translate into some kind of action yeah
but I really I I really believe very
strongly like there's no perfect parent
and you don't need to be a perfect
parent right I think that if parents can
be observant of their own histories
observant of how it plays out in their
homes like that puts you way ahead of
you know a lot of parents
I I also think that it's really really
important what you said about not
looking to kids much less teenagers for
gratification and I think what's hard is
often with kids it is enormously
gratifying it's so fun to parent kids
especially between ages six to ten it
really it's wonderful and delightful
but I feel like if you are approaching
if your kid is approaching adolescence
and you don't have in place a way to
feel good about yourself or you know
proud of your you know efforts you need
that before your kid hits adolescence
because you're not going to get it from
your kid yeah and and
I um I feel for people who in taking
care of their kids have given up things
that they themselves
really draw value from because I think
when their kid does become a teenager
and stops finding anything that the
parent does particularly Pleasant they
can feel pretty empty-handed yeah this
is a breach of the contrast exactly I
put in all this time there was a quid
pro quo here didn't you know that we
made a deal yeah it's like no we I
didn't make that deal yeah yeah
so your work historically has focused
primarily on on girls this is different
this new book uh because it it casts its
Gaze on on all teenagers so you know the
obvious question is like why this book
and and why now
so
um the why now
and the why of this book actually have
the same answer which was two factors
that came along one was the pandemic and
that was a time where you know the needs
of all teenagers came to the fore
and I have cared four boys and kids of
all genders over the course of my career
more girls than
boys or kids of other genders but
you know the it was so hard on the
teenagers to go through the pandemic and
it was hard on everybody but for
teenagers in particular
they have two jobs you know one is to
become increasingly independent and the
other is to spend as much time as
possible with their friends and the
pandemic undermined their ability to do
either and so I'd never seen I mean I've
been practicing for almost 30 years I'd
never seen suffering on the scale that
the pandemic brought about in teenagers
everywhere
the other force that
inspired me to write the book was that
the cultural discourse around what
mental health is
stopped squaring with how we understand
it as psychologists and moved to a place
where
a lot of the time it seems as though
being mentally healthy is equated with
feeling good or calm or relaxed or happy
I am all for people having those
feelings I would like for people to have
those feelings often
that does not inform how we think about
mental health and psychology it's not a
good definition of mental health and in
fact I think it actually sets up a very
fragile position for parents and kids if
that becomes the definition because
parent may be happy calm relaxed the kid
may be feeling that anything can come
along and mess that up
and I would never want people to think
that then their mental health is
suddenly up for grabs right they may be
having a very bad day
but it felt to me imperative to um
do work that help people make the
distinction between distress and a
mental health concern
because too often right now those are
spoken about in the same breath right
so two very important things covid and
then how we're conceptualizing mental
health let's I want to get to covid but
let's park that for now and just kind of
uh Riff on on the mental health
conversation because I think that's a
big one
um I couldn't agree more I think that
they're it's a situation in which you
know good intentions have gone awry like
there is a mental health conversation
going on right now that is helpful
people are thinking about it in ways
that didn't exist prior to the pandemic
um but it's a it's a situation where
there are unforeseen negative
consequences as a result uh everything
is a trauma we're all victims we're
coddling you know in the Jonathan height
kind of you know thesis of over coddling
uh people as parents we you know we're
so fearful of exposing our children to
any form of of risk or Peril and so
we're hovering and
um you know overly accommodating and
then you know these teens are then
running the household you know it's like
there's all sorts of crazy stuff that's
going on
um that is born out of this good idea of
of like how do we protect our kids how
do we prioritize their mental health so
distress on the one hand which you
characterize as you know maybe difficult
emotions but but appropriate given a
certain context that are responded to by
the parent from a perspective of trying
to make them go away and get you back to
a place of happiness you know let's fix
it let's fix it there's something if
you're not happy there's something wrong
with you like what does that do to a
young mind who's constantly being
impulsed with this message that if
you're not happy all the time if you're
not like experiencing passion and Bliss
and all of this that there's there's
some kind of pathology lingering inside
of you
does is it makes distress seem like the
bad guy
when
the way we view it in Psychology is that
distress is integral to human
functioning and for teenagers and of
course this is within limits but for
teenagers distress is part of how
actually all of us navigate the world
you know we know what feels good and
what doesn't and so we do you know more
of the things that feel good hopefully
and less of the things that you know are
having negative consequences
and for teenagers it is also growth
giving it's actually profoundly growth
giving when I think about the kids I've
worked with clinically
who have gone through something really
painful and I mean gone through it like
been allowed to have the experience and
find their way through I've never seen
maturation
happen at so rapid a pace and and what I
mean you know there may be a kid who you
know is confronted by a tragedy
something really awful happens and it's
extremely painful and we would wish that
it never happened but if they're helped
through it you end up with teenagers who
are philosophical and and broad-minded
in ways that you don't see usually at
that age or um if a teenager messes up
does something really dumb right like
cheats and gets caught
and has to sit with the consequences at
school and sit with the consequences at
home
those are the kids who in my practice
are saying things to me like
I never want to feel this way again like
I'm gonna organize myself around not
having to feel this or
this has made me think so much about the
kind of person I want to be and so I
find myself as a psychologist right now
in some ways trying to do PR for
distress right like it has a hugely
important Place really in all of our
lives and then especially for teenagers
feeling it helps them grow helps them
navigate
and then
knowing that they can find their way
through developing skill sets for
managing it is actually what allows them
to function autonomously it allows them
to move away from us go to places where
they don't necessarily know that it's
going to go well
because if they they consider it they
think well if a go if I go there and it
doesn't go well I can handle that like I
have it within myself to manage whereas
you know to answer your question kids
who
feel that they can only proceed in
circumstances where they know they won't
be uncomfortable
or they could be guaranteed that it's
going to go well end up on these
extraordinarily narrow paths right
because of very little of life has that
sure so for me I really think being able
to
accept distress and work one's way
through it
for teenagers in particular it's the
keys to the kingdom it is what lets them
move freely into the world right it's uh
it's it's similar to Susan David's you
know Notions around emotional resilience
yeah right like you can't develop that
type of resilience unless you allow you
put yourself in a position to fail and
kind of grapple with failure and
learning how to move forward and all of
those things especially at that time
when your brain is wiring a you know at
such a rapid rate right like there's
there seems to be a preciousness to this
period of time where this kind of thing
is more kind of mission critical than it
is later in life
I think it's true and and yet I think
that's also part of what makes it so
hard for parents to tolerate it is that
teenagers do make terrible mistakes and
sometimes life-changing mistakes right
um You have this phrase uh angst is the
price of admission yeah is that that you
came up with did you come up with that I
don't know that I did yeah that's great
though
I think it's great
um but yeah for the for the from the
point of view of the parent it then
becomes the job then becomes deciphering
what is a situation that that demands
some level of intervention and when is
the when is it appropriate for me to be
you know to take a step back and allow
this to unfold without intervening yeah
no I think it's a really tough call
um and there's no perfect science to it
right I mean that's the thing like I
have no answer that can tell a parent
here's how you'll know
um
and I think that one of the hardest
things about
raising a teenager is you actually
cannot guarantee your teenager safety
like there's nothing you can do to
guarantee that your teenager will not
find themselves in a position that's
truly dangerous
that is so scary I can say that both as
a parent and as a psychologist who cares
for kids
but I also know that fear is a terrible
position from which to parent
and that's something that also I think a
lot right now
about how hard it is to parent teenagers
you know we have these unrelenting
headlines about the Adolescent Mental
Health crisis about youth suicide
and I feel both glad that we're having
the conversation and also concerned
about what it feels like as a parent to
be seeing those headlines all the time
and how that would shape or inform
reacting to even more Garden variety
adolescent upset sure yeah and I
definitely want to dig into that but you
know in in thinking about like the media
there was one uh article in the Atlantic
a couple years ago that was all about
um accommodative parenting did you see
do you see this article it's like an
anxious child and the crisis of modern
parenting and it's really about the fear
that that the parents have you know when
they see these statistics and like oh my
God like all these teenage girls are are
having suicidal ideation and loneliness
and all this stuff like we've gotta make
sure that our kid is in their their
transferring all of that fear and that
pathology onto their child you know from
a place again of of best intentions but
there's a whole Downstream you know kind
of negative reaction you know when that
child is like it makes the kid feel
unsafe and then oh I guess I should be
afraid because my parents are so afraid
and then that's actually exacerbating
the situation that you're trying to to
you know ameliorate that's my big worry
now actually is that
are the best gift we can give our kids
especially our teenagers is to try to be
a steady presence
teenagers experience their own emotions
is very very powerful and destabilizing
and part of how they can feel more
secure is if they bring their emotions
to the parent and the parent can react
at least outwardly in a calm way right
and I think about
it's analog in raising younger kids you
know how like if your toddler is running
towards you and then they fall and
scrape their knee that they look at
their knee and then they look at your
face right and we're good we're really
good at that moment like what how am I
supposed to feel yeah you tell me this
how bad is it and we have a very
powerful and helpful Instinct in that
moment where we usually are like you're
okay you're okay even if inside we're
thinking oh God that looks pretty bad
the same is true for raising teenagers
that you know for them you know a failed
test uh you know ruptured friendship
feels disastrous like that's how they
experience emotions and they come home
to us and they lay it in front of us and
the best weak gift we can give them is
to be very empathic and very attentive
to it but not to react at that at their
level much less above it
and so I think the challenge right now
in parenting is how to have these
headlines all around
and try to be a steady presence in the
face of what is often Garden variety
adolescent distress but if this is your
first teenager or you don't do this for
a living how would you know that I think
it's really hard
yeah it seems to break down into into
two categories you have the teen
who is on the emotional roller coaster
and there's lots of chaos and and you
know kind of externalization of of of of
emotions that get dumped on the parents
and then you have the the young person
that internalizes everything and says
I'm fine goes to the room and shuts the
door so what are the differences in how
you interface with those two archetypes
that are on the kind of I mean it's all
on a spectrum of course but you know it
would seem to me that there would be a
differential in like how to think about
and approach those two types of young
people
so when I think about teenagers I often
think about them as talkers or not
talkers right and parents in audiences
you can almost tell by the looks on
their faces who's got which type of
teenager
so there are kids who come home and
share a huge amount and their kids who
come home and are very very quiet and
that is hard on parents and it's
especially hard on parents when they can
tell the kid is in pain
and so what I tried to introduce in this
book was how we as psychologists think
about emotion regulation
um which is that we think about it as a
two-sided thing there's expressing
emotions to get relief from them and
there's actually raining them back in
controlling emotions which we put
actually on equal footing in terms of
their value to overall emotion
regulation which may come as a surprise
to some people because we've really
moved as a culture very much to the side
of like if there's a feeling the best
thing to do is to talk about it you know
maybe to excavate it to talk it to death
sometimes maybe but we actually see
there's a huge wide range of other
options that will really be useful
but what I can say fundamentally back to
your sort of these extreme examples
is our ideal is that you see a little
bit of bowls both the capacity to gain
Relief by expressing emotions and the
capacity to tame emotions when needed
and this is true both in the home around
Garden variety adolescent distress
it's also how we think clinically if a
teenager is all expression if their
emotions are running the show calling
all the shots we actually think how do
we get these more tamed how do we get
these under control and if a teenager is
entirely reserved shut down bottled up
we think clinically okay what's it going
to take for this young person to find a
way to express
so most of the time kids are actually
doing a little bit of both back and
forth
it's not comfortable for them all the
time it's not comfortable for their
family all the time but as far as
psychologists are concerned they're
doing great
um what we watch out for are the
extremes yeah
we're brought to you today by Roca
glasses are not something you normally
think about as a piece of performance
gear which when you think about it is
kind of insane because you can't perform
at your best if you can't see well the
Geniuses at Roka basically rebuilt
eyewear from the ground up no matter how
active you are or how much you sweat
these things never slip or fall off your
face they're super durable they look
awesome and they've got tons of super
classy modern styles to choose from I've
been rocking rocas for about four years
at this point I love them I'm a big fan
of the Hamilton style and gloss black
that's this Frame right here as well as
clear or I guess they call them vintage
on the website and if you want to try
them out for yourself you can do that
right now and unlock 20 off your order
with the code richroll
roca.com or you can click the link in
the description below okay back to the
show
foreign
so in the in the book you kind of you
break this down into two different
pieces you have the the the management
of emotions and then you have the
regaining of you know kind of control of
your of of their kind of emotional
regulatory system or their Equanimity
um and then there's a whole kind of
discourse around the you know in the
management of their emotions how to
discern when this is healthy versus
problematic and just because a teen
comes home and like dumps some crazy
story on you and tells you you're
horrible and slams the door they're
externalizing whatever is going on with
them emotionally that might be a healthy
response to whatever is happening to not
be reactive to that your job is to kind
of you know be be you know just just be
Placid in the face of that chaos as a
stable Force for that person and resist
the temptation to solve the problem for
the child
that's right but what I would say is
it's important that we have parameters
around how emotions get expressed so the
kid may come home and be really angry
and have had a terrible day
and I would never say they shouldn't be
given a lot of room to express their
frustration and their annoyance you know
with how they the day went down
what we're really going to train our
attention on as psychologists is whether
they express those emotions or tame
those emotions in ways that bring relief
and Do no harm or whether there's a cost
to how they're going about it
so actually if a kid comes home and just
like salts the Earth at home as a way to
deal with the expression of their
frustration that's costly right they're
tearing at their relationships at home
that's not something I would want to
allow
but that doesn't mean I'd want the
parent to you know engage with them full
blast but I think there may be room once
you know things have settled a little
bit and cooled off to come back to that
teenager and say look you have every
right to be angry about what happened at
school like I agree like that's a pretty
lousy thing
you can't express it in a way that
damages relationships or hurts other
people and you or you you can't express
it that way so here's how you can
express it you can say this this and
this and this you can you know if you
want to go out and like kick a soccer
ball if you want to like you know go
scream to a pillow like you can do all
these things that have no cost
but you can't come home and lay waste to
family life because you had everything
just like torch the house yeah and then
the half-life of these things is always
pretty short you know then it's sort of
like what are you talking about like
everything's fine you know I will tell
you I think the all-time art of raising
a teenager is not holding a grudge yeah
I think that is really they time is
different for them I've always felt that
teenagers are like dog years you know
like a year for us is like seven for
them I think an hour for that us is like
seven for them so we can still be really
sore about something that happened and
like truly they are so far past it they
don't even think about what right like
you're still thinking about that like
they're on 10 they're 10 steps down the
road you know so I think that
if we're gonna enjoy our teenagers which
we should I think a lot of it is saying
our piece around behavior when we need
to but then meeting them where they are
and if they're in a better place like
Let It Go Get There mm-hmm
and and what about the child who is
internalizing everything who's reclusive
you know that often leaves the parent
in a state of distress because they just
they just don't know what's going on
right like they may think well that kid
doesn't seem
uh you know well attuned to his or her
environments doesn't quite seem happy
but we don't really know what's going on
and that can be a real a scary place for
for a parent and then you know what is
the typical kind of parent response to
that where do parents go wrong and
trying to decipher that and understand
what's happening so that they can you
know be of Maximum service yeah no it's
interesting sometimes I'll be with an
audience and a parent will tell a story
about their kid who just talks and talks
and talks and complains and complains
and complains and then another penal
raise their hand and say I wish my kid I
wish my kid were telling me what's going
on because it is as you describe it's so
long it's worrisome to parents
so the first thing I would want to rule
out right you know like clinicians so we
think about like what do you want to
rule out in terms of how worried to be
so one is like is the kid using
substances like a lot right and when we
think about ways that emotions get tamed
substances are extremely effective and
extremely powerful and that is one of
the you know kind of high likelihood
ways if a kid's gonna handle their
emotions tame them in a way that's going
to be costly that's a very high
likelihood way to do it so first
question I'd have is you know as a kid
abusing right is a kid using substances
in a way that's concerning and then you
deal with that
the other way that kids tame emotions
that can be very problematic over time
is by sort of chronic distraction that
you know they have an uncomfortable
feeling and then they are on video games
for hours and distraction has its place
in helping us maintain our emotional
equilibrium
but um
some kids are working so hard to not
feel things that they are constantly
distracting themselves and often
technology is where this is happening so
much so that it starts to cost them in
other areas right they're not making
friendships they're not getting their
schoolwork done
so in terms of like levels of when to
worry about a kid who's very reserved or
not sharing with a parent
I would first you know worry about
substances worry about constant
distraction and Tackle those as the
problems they are
then they're the kids who just aren't
big talkers right they're just not big
talkers or they're very private
and there are a couple of ways that
parents can think about how to
um
change that with their kid
one is
teenagers are organized around autonomy
they want to become increasingly
independent
and so it shouldn't surprise us that
they may not be in the mood to answer
our questions when we are asking them
right if we're at dinner like okay how
was school you know what happened it
happens all the time the parents are
like your kid's like fine nothing right
and so
one thing I was so delighted to discover
in writing this book
is something that was happening in my
home and that I think a lot of families
think is just happening in their home is
that the kid who tells them nothing
after school at dinner asking great
questions parents getting nothing
Waits until the parent is in bed and
then is suddenly standing there as
chatty as can be and
when I realized this was like near
Universal like this was happening in so
many homes I thought okay well this is
fascinating and what I think is
happening is the teenager
is satisfying two needs at once they
want to be autonomous but they want to
connect with a parent and so if they
wait till we're in bed they decide if
there's going to be a meeting they
decide the content of the meeting
because they know we're not going to
bring up new topics at that time and
they decide when it ends so
what I would say is maybe your kid's not
a nighttime talker but I have become
increasingly aware there are kids who
don't want to talk when the parent wants
to talk
but they will text with the parents or
they will have conversations in the car
that they need a lot of tight control
over the conversation in order to have
it
the other scenario that comes up is that
the teenager doesn't want to talk
because they the parents stepped in it
the parent did something
when they did talk that made the kid
uncomfortable about opening up
and when I've asked teenagers like you
know you know that thing where you're
clearly upset and your parents asking
what's wrong and you know you're just
shaking them off shaking them off
they're like hey I'm like what what's
the deal like what's the deal and
they're like well there's a few
different reasons
so the reasons they give me they say
well sometimes it's because we know what
you're gonna say
so I'm upset because I messed up my math
test and it's the math test that you
asked me if I was ready for and I told
you I was but it turns out I was not and
so if I if I tell you that that's the
issue I'm gonna basically get and I told
you so and I don't want to hear it so I
can't tell you
another reason they'll give me is
they'll say You're Gonna blab right so
I'm gonna tell you about something
that's happening for me or a friend and
then the next thing I know you're going
to be on the horn either with the school
or with the neighbor or with your sister
and I did not mean for this to leave the
house and so I'm not telling you stuff
um and then I thought this was so
beautiful a girl said to me here's the
deal
by the time I get home I am 90 of the
way over whatever I was upset about and
rehashing the whole thing from my
parents is not gonna help me feel better
so I think we sometimes want to be
attentive that like they know us
they we may have stepped in it and if we
have we have to apologize and try to you
know repair that and I think teenagers
can be pretty forgiving you know if
you're earnestly apologetic I think you
can open channels of communication
there's so much in that yeah I mean a
lot allowing the the team to set the
parameters for these types of
discussions not trying to force them
trying to uh refrain from judgment or
you know stepping into the you know on
these land mines that are are typically
the things that that cut off
communication right uh resisting the
urge to try to solve the problem or step
in and intervene or like tell some story
about what happened to you when they you
were that age which is like the worst
right and the conversation I would say
like that's the last thing they want to
hear right when I was a teenager is like
the most conversation ending thing you
can possibly say as you know
um I mean I've just learned because we
have a quieter child and and it's funny
because just the other night like that
exact thing happened like right when I
was going to bed you know
um
and you have to just
like you live for those moments because
you can't compel them so you have to
like
be in a place of of sort of surrender
around it and then when they happen you
you have to have the you like have to
have the awareness like oh okay it's hap
I have to I have to turn on now because
this is a fleeting thing you know it
doesn't happen that often it requires a
lot of patience it does it really really
does so here's how I think we summon
that patience
first of all this is really short-lived
and and one of the things I'm so glad
about is that I was practicing before I
had kids and I had so many people I was
caring for so many parents say oh my
gosh it goes so fast like they're out so
fast because my personality is a bit
more on the controlling side and I know
that if I didn't have that professional
reminder all of the time of how
short-lived this would be
I know I would have been like clean up
your shoes or in the wrong place and let
me go to sleep I mean I know I would
have demanded more in that way
and so um and now I have a kid in
college right and and it's true and so
for me in those moments where I'm like
oh really right now I think you know
what in three years I would give my left
arm to have you come in to talk to me
right like I'm not gonna know where you
are at 11 o'clock at night so I think
that helps and then the other thing I
think
is more important than it's ever been
is that the single most powerful force
for adolescent mental health is strong
relationships with caring adults so we
have to meet them more than halfway we
just have to
um
I think most parents are caring
but they don't know how to deploy that
care in in a helpful manner right it
goes back to Good Intentions Gone Gone
awry so when they say you know how a
school which I do every day like I make
all these mistakes it's very by the way
it's very refreshing that you spent your
entire life studying this stuff still
you know guys
[Music]
um
uh you know it gets it wrong but
yeah of course I mean I don't know I
mean I feel like they need to know that
that
um that they're safe I try to you know
Reserve judgment like to me maintaining
that open channel of communication is
the most important thing and the minute
you inject any kind of like judgment
into it or
um
you know attitude about like a certain
Behavior or thing like that's only going
to restrict that's gonna like you said
earlier it's gonna make them think twice
about opening up to you next time yeah
it's funny the thing you know I I my
favorite thing to do is to be with
teenagers and just ask you know like
what does that adults do that don't
doesn't work for you or what is it that
adults don't understand
and one thing I've been hearing from
them a lot is don't compare us don't
compare us I think so often again in a
well-meaning way parents are like you
know your brother didn't do that or you
know why can't you be more like or when
I was a teenager like I didn't
and it just rubs them the wrong way so
much you know Betty's son yeah he's
doing great yeah what's up with you you
know and and again I'm with you I I
don't think any parent is setting Out To
Do Wrong by their kid like I I think we
are desperate to do right by our kids
and there's almost nothing in parenting
that I would point to that is not well
intentioned
but the best thing about teenagers is
that they will tell us straight up what
does and does not work for them and I
think we need to take it seriously
um so we talked a little bit about the
the managing of the emotions part and
then there's the the regaining control
aspect
um how are you know how our teens you
know what are they what are they looking
to to kind of self-regulate like is it
taking a bath with essential oils or is
it you know going on a video game for
six hours or sticking their head in a
bong like it can be all of these
different things right and I thought
what was really interesting in the book
was
look uh if a kid has a hard day and they
come home and then they there's one
example of one one teen who then you
know plays a video game for an hour or
whatever and that's what he needs to
kind of like down regulate and then he
he gets what he needs out of it and then
he's ready to like focus on his homework
or like you know he's okay right and
that's very different from the person
who can't stop scrolling or has a you
know a more malignant relationship to
whether it's technology or substance or
or whatever it is and so from the
parental point of view again it goes
back to how do you discern the healthy
you know response versus the unhealthy
one
so
two ways to slice this one is we really
have to be deliberate about allowing
teeming efforts to be seen as a healthy
response at all like I think our culture
is so much defaulted right now too if my
kid's upset the right the script I'm
operating on is they come home they tell
me what they're upset about I give them
good advice they feel better that's the
script yeah okay it's terrible script
right or rarely at it just doesn't
happen that often right yeah so the
first thing we have to do is actually
expand our understanding of what the
options are so ways that kids can manage
a bad day that are entirely acceptable
in the Canon of psychological research
would be coming home and rolling around
on the floor with a dog for a while
right or coming home and going for a run
because that helps them feel better or
taking a shower or
maybe happen on a video game just for a
little while
what we're always going to measure is
whether there's a cost Associated right
so there's a lot of ways that kids
regulate emotion that first of all we
don't even recognize and value that I
think we need to
and then if a parent starts to be
uncomfortable like I don't know they've
been on the video game for a while right
this is going on and on the way to
evaluate it is what's the cost of this
right is there work they're supposed to
be doing have they been you know
sedentary for a long time are they not
seeing friends
and so you know that's that's the
measure like we just don't want there to
be a price tag attached to what kids do
but the fun thing about caring for
teenagers and getting to write about
them is to really celebrate like they're
good at regulating emotion and
one of the big ones huge in the lives of
teenagers is actually music you know
that they will come home and they'll use
it both to express emotion and actually
to contain emotion so it happens all the
time that if a kid is sad like I would
say most teenagers have a sad playlist
like they actually collect this music
that they will
um come home or wherever they are
they'll be sad and they will
deliberately put on their sad playlist
with the intention of crying alongside
it
to express the emotions so that they can
get to feeling better faster and it
works beautifully harmless effective
the same teenager or other teenagers
will sometimes actually have mood
countering music like they'll be in a
bad place where they'll have low energy
and so they have their upbeat or you
know pump up or had a teenager describe
it as yeah yeah playlist that was a
great name
and so they they're always using these
extraordinary
you know adaptive tools and I think as
adults we too often miss it and we think
why aren't they talking to us about
their feelings when in fact they've got
such good stuff going on how do you get
them to be so open with you oh well
first of all I'm not their parents yeah
I mean yeah
um second of all they know I'm it's time
limited
um I also think
and this is I'm sad about this I also
think
it's not that often the teenagers
encounter adults who are
absolutely fascinated by them in a
totally benign way and I hope it is
totally benign I believe it is we're
pretty biased against teenagers as a
culture like you can say about teenagers
things you could could and never should
say you shouldn't say about teenagers
about any other group right I mean
people are
wholesale dismissive of teenagers you
know they're so impulsive they're so
difficult you know I mean it's
extraordinary actually what we allow
ourselves to say about teenagers and
teenagers are well aware of that that
adults often cast a sort of you know
unpleasant eye on them and I am
absolutely convinced that teenagers can
smell at 300 yards you know adults who
um
don't regard them you know with a whole
lot of respect and they can also smell
at 300 yards adults who um honestly I
just love them it's clear I mean your
curiosity your fascination with them
yeah it's very it's disarming oh well
and I think for teenagers they're like
all right lady like you're like really
asking so we will really tell you all
right yeah somebody just had to ask
earnestly yeah right and you like seem
to really want an answer and you're not
gonna fight us when we tell you the
answer right
um I I was speaking at a school recently
to a upper school
high school and um I heard I had a great
conversation with teenagers like we had
a great time but I heard after the fact
that they were like oh we have a speaker
oh man she can talk to us about social
media like that they were just waiting
to just have a grown-up come down on
them like they're so accustomed to it
right
um so we can't pivot to talk about
social media right now well let's go
back to the uh to the to the covid thing
I mean that was a big impetus for you
writing this book and obviously there's
no there's no shortage of
press out there about what's happening
with teens
that is a director in direct results of
of lockdowns and what everyone
experienced the rates of loneliness and
depression and suicide Etc are like
through the roof it's pretty alarming so
how are you thinking about this like
give me your take on what it is that
teens specifically had to endure during
that period of time and the the sort of
short and long-term impact that it's
having on their development yeah
um
I mean it was I had in my home I had a
high schooler and a elementary school
student so I was living with it in my
home
and
the isolation alone
was torture
for a lot of teenagers
um they are just not designed to be
stuck at home with their parents it's
really the opposite of what they should
be doing
and we saw all sorts of things right
incredibly sad teenagers we saw an
explosion of eating disorders and
um
huge anxiety that in some ways we've
seen the aftermath of the anxiety or the
impact of that more now that we're
asking kids to be out in the world right
when kids were required to be at home
they were anxious but they weren't asked
to do anything so their anxiety didn't
actually get stirred up but we are
seeing now across like all districts
like regardless of socioeconomic status
incredible School truancier chronic
absenteeism or you know you could call
it a lot of things but kids just not
going to school like that is something
we are continuing to see
so there were things we know we saw in
the pandemic there are some things we
know we're seeing now so we are seeing
the school truancy question
I think we're still waiting on the data
on what the longer term effects will be
um there was a report that just came out
that was very concerning that reported a
lot of um it was the CDC report a lot of
loneliness a lot of despair
what's tricky about that report is those
data were collected in the fall of 2021
and they were asking about mood over the
previous year
so when those data came out in February
of this year I went and actually looked
at some writing I had done around that
time in the fall of 2021 about where
we're teenagers they were so miserable
like as a group they were so miserable
because what was happening for them is
they were starting their third school
year disrupted by the pandemic and so
even kids who were going back they were
often going back in masks which they had
strong feelings about
a lot of kids were really anxious about
returning socially a lot of kids were
really scared about getting covered
and even the kids for whom things on the
surface looked really good they were
telling me they're going to take it all
away like we're gonna settle back in and
it's gonna all get ripped away from us
again
so I'm grateful for those data because
they map on to what we were seeing at
the time and I think the thing that's so
hard is there's such a long lag between
the collection of the data and the
release of the data so I'm very eager to
see you know what we find out in a year
because anecdotally we're seeing like in
general kids who are able to go to
school and are back at school in general
like they look pretty good right we have
kids who continue to suffer tremendously
more than there were before the pandemic
but there also was suffering before the
pandemic and we have kids who without
question were knocked off of their
developmental trajectory by the pandemic
but on the whole a lot of teenagers are
looking like teenagers you know and in
the ways that I have recognized for my
whole career
so we're still trying to figure it out
right so so that study I mean I saw a
study recently I don't know if it's the
same one that said something like six
out of ten girls
were reported being persistently sad or
hopeless
um or something like 30 percent of teen
girls had contemplated suicide I don't
know if that's the same it's the same
study so it's reporting back from that
period of time so then the question
becomes how resilient are they are they
bouncing back or not
um you know what can we learn and what
what you know where where might we be
going wrong by reading too much into
this I suppose
that is a worry I have which is when
those data come out and
a lot of the way it gets reported
leaves readers with the impression these
are fresh numbers
I think it's very scary to parents and
then I have concerns as a psychologist
of like well if we if we terrify parents
that does not actually make it easier
for them to serve as a steady presence
in the face of adolescent emotionality
so there's this very delicate dance of
both wanting to raise awareness making
sure we are incredibly attentive to
warning signs and when we should be
I'm very concerned about teenagers and
speeding them towards care
versus also not rejecting all of that
putting everybody on the ceiling right
um
the other wrinkle to that also has to do
with gender differences which we haven't
talked about yet
um
in the most General sense girls are
going to be more likely to kind of
report their emotions right whereas boys
process these challenging times
differently and perhaps are more likely
to be acting out than reporting that
they're anxious or depressed or or sad
right so that also skews the the
viability of those data points
I mean so these are self-report studies
so they're asking about distress
the girls who were surveyed reported a
great deal of distress exactly what you
said we would expect to see the
corollary the one of the rules in
Psychology is girls collapse in on
themselves under distress boys tend to
act out
I don't know that you're going to get a
super faithful accounting all the time
of boys describing all of the ways they
were hard on their family or the people
around them as an expression of distress
and so um the girls do come out looking
pretty bad relative to boys but I'm not
sure that's a very
um detailed or subtle or nuanced picture
of what was happening for boys who also
can mask their sadness just by
withdrawal right but even under the most
kind of liberal or generous you know
review of that study or those data
points it's clear like it's not great no
matter how you split it like it's a [__]
show and we should be paying attention
and try to understand what was driving
that and how to you know kind of course
correct that right like similarly you
know we had uh uh now 15 who 13 year old
and it was really hard really hard like
very lonely and very difficult and of
course the isolation is gonna drive more
screen time more social media usage
which is then you know compelling that
person to be in that mode of comparison
and these people are living their lives
this way but I'm over here and like
that's driving low self-esteem like
there's you know there's a lot going on
there right so
social media is not um benign in any of
this so how do you wrap your head around
that or or you know speak about that
when you go out and talk to kids in
schools and in your counseling
so the social media research has
complicated the views on it are
complicated
um
here's my take on it I have a lot of
thoughts about it but here's some one is
when I think about kids in the pandemic
and social media part of me is like
thank goodness they had a way to stay
plugged in I mean can you imagine if
during our own adolescence we were stuck
in the house like we were and like three
channels three channels and one phone
line right I mean that would have been
even worse I think in many ways so their
ability to stay connected had value
the thing that make made me nervous and
continues to make me very nervous about
social media is the algorithm-driven
nature of what kids are presented and so
that anything a kid I think most people
know this but I think it's still worth
articulating actually anything a kid or
that we
spends time looking at or searches for
or likes or comments on the algorithms
driving these
um social media platforms we'll pick
that data up and then present them more
of that in the aim of getting them to
not be able to look away
and what I think about with those
algorithms are norms that teenagers are
very vulnerable to the Norms in their
environment and so when I think back to
the like the Eating Disorders finding
where we just saw so many eating
disorders in the pandemic
there's a pretty decent consensus that
probably what drove a lot of that is
that we have kids who are home they have
tons of time on their hands they have
tons of like energy to do something so
they do a little searching for Fitness
or weight control or whatever the
algorithms pick this up and start
flooding their feeds with
imagery related to dieting or advice on
dieting and in the absence of leaving
the home doing other things looking at
other people this becomes the norm and
it no longer seems strange to you know
Ultra
diet do things that are actually really
really dangerous
and so when I worry about social media
what I worry about is that it can shift
the norms for kids and change what they
think to be typical and so
um there are a couple of situations that
I was aware of clinically where it was
actually the older sister who went to
parents about I think it was in both
cases a 13 year old boy saying you all
need to know
he went down a white supremacy rabbit
hole and is way down it
and the parents like didn't know had
didn't really have no but for these boys
who are home nothing else going on this
becomes normed and things that should be
horrifying
start to just become kind of standard
right gets normalized yeah yeah it's
really scary uh you know obviously in
the in the teen girl context it's issues
around body dysmorphia Etc you know they
can be quite pernicious
um but there's something particularly uh
scary about The Lonely disenfranchised
young male teen who you know is looking
for an identity and is vulnerable and
stumbles upon you know whether it's
Andrew Tate or some you know some other
kind of emblem of toxic masculinity that
that is then telling that person you
know something that's that's nourishing
them in a negative way unbeknownst to
oversight or parents or anything like
that I mean this is pervasive right and
you know that young person who can kind
of unbeknownst to you know their parents
or whoever for a period of time is down
a certain kind a rabbit hole like that
this is this becomes a very volatile you
know potentially dangerous situation
it's not like Scott Galloway talks about
this all the time like that you know the
the the
um
you know the the lonely young man is a
very danger can be a very dangerous
thing and and there is a a certain type
of Crisis around that right now yeah no
we're
with that and
and yet in the spirit of not terrifying
parents and leaving it there you know
one of the things I would say is make
sure you know what's on your kids for
you page of tick tock right I mean that
there are ways for parents to acquaint
themselves that's tricky though I know
that is very as a yeah I can tell you
yeah you know there's all kinds of
finsta accounts and like you know
multiple accounts like I you know it's
very hard yeah for a parent to like
delicately dance around that like you
want your child to have some autonomy
and and you know respect their privacy
not be invasive while also being able to
kind of monitor that is easier said than
done it is true it is true the other
thing I would say is delay delay as much
as you can on social media
um when I talk with high schoolers
they're like we're not the ones you need
to be worried about it's the seventh
graders and I think that's often there's
that I think that they're you know
seventh graders are you know 12 to 13
they're very Concrete in their thinking
they're not necessarily able to stand
back from what they're looking at and
wonder like what is behind this or why
might this be happening
I don't think it's true that the high
schoolers are entirely insulated from it
anymore but I also take them at their
word that if you you know if you really
want to worry about this like you should
be worried about the seventh graders or
the eighth graders who are going down
these roads and one thing parents can
consider is when kids are asking for
access
a lot of times it's so they can stay
connected and be connected and a lot of
times having the ability to text their
friends will go pretty far for a while
that when we give kids technology or we
give kids phones I don't think parents
should feel like they hand over the
whole thing at once you can give
I have given a young teenager a phone
that has no browser no social media apps
the ability to text and ride that as
long as you can while the brain is
developing and perspective is coming in
yeah you talk about this in the book
like
the young person is so desperate to get
onto these social media apps that you're
in a position of power to dictate terms
right you're like okay well we'll do
that but then I'm gonna have to be I'm
gonna have to have the login credential
and so like they'll agree to that
because they want to they want to be on
online so badly absolutely I miss that
whole boat by the way well a lot of
parents do right I mean it's mostly it's
a hazard to be a psychologist parent
occasionally though it gives me the leg
up right because I've seen these things
before I have to do them in my own home
and and I think truly what it is is that
kids want to be able to show their
friends they have the device I mean
often like that is more powerful than I
think a lot of adults realize and so you
truly can say all right you want the
device you can have the device
you know and it will have all these
parameters around it and it also will
not go in your bedroom right that's
that's a great one to start with
um and if you can ride that all the way
through high school that is fantastic
but if you but if that has already been
breached good luck reversing it's very
hard to it is very hard to get that
horse back in the barn I I will be the
first to admit so all those parents of
younger kids out there this is a great
rule to start with as opposed to try to
implement later
um and kids will agree to anything to
get their hands on the device so make
the most of your leverage in that moment
yeah I often think about the ratio like
it's it's it's how you interface and use
these things right like are you using
them to create or to consume like in a
very binary sense like are you like on
Photoshop and making cool photo you know
sharing making videos that you can share
is there some kind of creative
stimulation aspect to it where you're
contributing or are you just receiving
and consuming
um and then beyond that on you know the
kind of social piece
um I found to your point about how
teenager teenagers are so creatively
adaptive like during the pandemic and
even now
um I found like our kids will just have
FaceTime on with their friend and like
they're not it's just on in the room
while they're doing homework or doing
whatever else so they feel connected to
somebody else even though they're alone
in their room and maybe they'll talk to
each other here and there but it's just
like this idea like oh we're together
even though we're not together yeah like
what it like that's a use case that I
don't think any adult would have ever
conceptualized but I think that's a
pretty common thing now right absolutely
which is cool like I think that's a good
like that's a cool workaround for that
piece of technology yeah no it's it's
very scary I know a lot of kids who
study that way you know and I I I am
I've entertained it myself with time so
not you know you have a big bunch of
work and you feel sort of isolated with
it if they're if you weren't alone you
know you'd feel better
it's an interesting I'll tell you where
it takes a very interesting turn
is um it makes it can make adolescent
romances very wall to wall you know that
when teenagers are dating one another
um it's not uncommon for them to wake up
text each other
good morning have each other on all the
time be in constant contact I mean
honestly vastly more connection than I
have with my own spouse it sounds
terrible
they like it but then what's interesting
is if the relationship ends I mean the
size of the whole it leaves in The Young
Person's life is just enormous because
they have had such pervasive connection
what about the notion of of you know
group identity and the politics around
that like I just can't fathom
being a teenager and being able to know
what everyone in my class is doing all
the time you know whether I'm included
whether I'm disincluded and if I'm
disincluded being able to like see them
out in the world doing that thing that I
wasn't invited to do and then in the
comments section everybody you know
taking others down a Peg and the
bullying that happens there like it just
sounds horrific I know I know I don't
you look at that and think oh we were so
lucky 100 so lucky like we're just naive
to all the things we weren't invited to
and this psychic pain that that must
cause and you must see that in your
practice every day I do and I truly will
say you know it's interesting there are
things that we can collapse that we
don't want to collapse so we don't want
to collapse social media or technology
because like you say like these have a
lot of facets that are interesting and
often adaptive for kids
and we also don't want to collapse
teenager because truly 12 11
no 12 13 14.
is so different from 16 17 18 in terms
of their ability to navigate these
things so where I would say that really
Exquisite pain around what you're just
describing that's younger teens 12 13
14.
um because they are still working so
hard to establish identity and they are
still trying to figure out where they
fit in and they don't have that
solidified usually yet
and so it is exquisitely painful and
they are watching that so so so
attentively whereas typically and this
is a little delayed by the pandemic but
it's it's I think coming back to more
the Norms we've known before by
sophomore year 15 years old kids tend to
be like nope I know who my friends are
and I know what we're up to and I'm not
so anxious about what everybody else is
doing
and so
just in terms of trying to um narrow the
scope of when parents want to be really
attentive about this or when they want
to worry or when they want to try to
delay delay delay on access it's not all
of adolescence it's it's I would say
through seventh eighth maybe early ninth
grade where that is the hardest hmm
I'm just imagining the marginalized kid
who isn't invited then goes home and
compulsively goes online to see to kind
of bear witness to the thing that he was
you know disincluded from and that only
feeds like a deeper sense of of
insecurity and and you know uh lowering
the self-esteem Etc and you know yes as
you get a little bit older and you kind
of emerge out of that but that's going
to calcify right and then that's going
to become very difficult to repair once
that sense of self-identity kind of
cements it could be it could be whereas
prior to that sorry to interrupt but
like prior to that yeah they're
disincluded but they go home and they
forget about it because they have other
things that nourish them outside of the
classroom but to your point earlier like
you're never away like you're always
connected you're always on yeah
and that piece I mean it's just so much
information right to try to metabolize
and take in
um what I will say is thank goodness for
the kids you're describing
we are now back in a position where
there could be activities that that
could be participating in things that
could be set up in terms of after school
so maybe maybe it's not going great with
the pure
landscape at school but then I would say
get that kid busy with other things
right that they need to be in traffic
patterns where they're around other kids
where they may find other friends
um and part of what was so horrible
about the pandemic is that all of that
went away and the other thing that went
away that we don't talk about nearly
enough is it part of what is so
important for teenagers is actually
connection with caring adults outside
the home that so much of what's good for
teenagers happens with like the fabulous
teacher or The Fabulous Coach or the
great boss or whatever and teenagers
lost all that too in the pandemic and so
when we're looking for explanations of
where things want to arrive for
teenagers that's one that I think like
deserves a lot more consideration than
we've given it
um I think that's a really important
point that
the impact of you know coaches mentors
teachers like it takes a village kind of
thing and even before the pandemic you
know we have seen the you know kind of
um exacerbation of of isolation the
dissolution of the kind of Village
notion of you know how we live and you
know certainly in Los Angeles it's so
dispersed the notion of community is
theoretical at best so I think there's a
general kind of denigration of that
notion that covid you know and the
lockdowns and all of that just
exacerbated and now even on the other
side of it
[Music]
we still haven't
um I mean we're still kind of in the
wake of it right like still it's like
well we'll Zoom for that instead of go
to per like we've acclimated to certain
lifestyle habits because of that
experience that I don't think are
necessarily all that healthy and
definitely not in service to the young
people I think that's right so then if
we think about okay well so there's an
opening
you know I think about all of us looking
at these youth mental health headlines
worried about the crisis and what I
would say is even if you're not yourself
raising teenagers you can help with this
right that there are ways in which
adults can make meaningful connections
with teenagers either through mentorship
or you know being a great boss or being
an incredible neighbor or an Incredible
uncle right I mean sometimes
teenagers will have like really powerful
relationships with
family members who weren't their parents
that will help them through incredible
things sure they they need that because
they can't hear it from their parents
like the parents are not supposed to be
the people who are kind of let me let me
sit you down and give you the life
advice they they don't want to hear from
their parents but they will hear it from
that other Elder that they sort of
respect and and maybe Revere who just
has
that ability to connect with them that a
parent you know will never be able to
have yeah no I I would say a huge
percentage of my clinical work is saying
the exact same thing that the parents
themselves would say or have said but
they can hear it from me yeah I mean I'm
like I'm sorry that I need to charge you
for this because you are covering this
at home but this yeah that's a lot of
the work yeah and and when those moments
arise and the and and the kid is talking
to you
um you know another Mantra that I always
use is just tell me more like instead of
let me tell you how to fix this or I
can't believe you did like judgment like
we're you know like not trying to solve
the problem not telling them what they
did wrong but just oh that must be hard
like tell me more about what that must
be like if I can and I'm not saying I'm
great at this but when I can do that
like that seems to be something that
will
you know create a little bit of a safe
Zone that will make the kid open up even
a little bit more yeah I'll tell you my
version of that is I am
I always work with the assumption that
teenagers have two sides that they have
a you know the side that maybe did the
Dome thing and it's impulsive and maybe
immature and you know maybe
self-centered
and they also have a side that is
philosophical and broad-minded and
you know an excellent self-advocate and
deeply thoughtful and so even when a kid
is telling me about something that feels
you know like they should totally not
have done that or you know like it was
just a really bonehead move
one of the ways I'll try to engage it is
I'll try to talk to the broad-minded
side about what happened like gosh
that's so not like you like what do you
make of that like how do you understand
that you did that
and and I find they usually rise to it
like that the side of the teenager you
talk to is the side you end up in
conversation with so if you come down
and I'm like what was that well then
you're gonna get you know go you don't
understand and you know that that
reactive part of the teenager and if you
even if you don't see it if you talk to
that vastly more mature side it will
usually show up and how do you how do
you balance that against the idea that
you know young people need guard rails
they want to you know they feel more
secure when they know there are rules
and there's you know ramifications for
breaking those rules and not that
anybody should be some kind of rigorous
Taskmaster but there is wisdom and kind
of reinforcing some kind of framework
around what's okay and what's not and
there's you know there's there's you
know ramifications for those breaches
um I think they can live side by side so
when we look at the research and when we
distill all of it on like what kids need
at home it's two things they need warmth
and they need need structure so I think
you can actually bring both so say a kid
does something really that they should
not have done you can have the structure
of saying all right that comes with
consequences right you know there's a
breach of trust we got to be able to
trust you to let you go out and about so
you will be hanging out with us for the
next couple of weekends
and then the warmth can come and be like
what happened like that's so not like
you like that it's not an either or
um right and and I would just say you
know if parents are like where am I
supposed to be in all of this if they
just keep going back to that idea
you want to be warm they want to you
want to feel you're you want your kids
to feel that you both love them and also
actually like them
and you want to have structure that
there should be a predictability to
family life that the rules should make
sense that the rules should be enforced
that kids are going to know what's going
to happen and kids do like rules
teenagers do like rules they don't like
loosey-goosey adults
um I think all the time about moments in
my practice where a teenager would float
in front of me something like um oh you
know we were at Susie's house and
Susie's Mama buy for us and they put it
out in this way like you know and I'll
go really and they go I know it's so
weird I don't know why she does that and
and I've learned that they'll often um
present something kind of neutrally to
like check to see how you respond
and even when
they've seem to be neutral to like
positive about it if I've stayed with my
gut and been like what they're like
thank you right they're so glad I think
of another example
I was caring for the kid of a
pediatrician in my community and it came
up
that
she was having her boyfriend was staying
overnight in her bedroom
um
and they were in high school which so in
America like that's not really very
typical and and I said oh your folks
were okay with that and she said I know
I don't know why they are you know and
and she had presented it like um
this is just kind of happening and when
I called the question she she it turns
out she was asking me a question and
telling me about it that's super
interesting
wild yeah
the best thing here's the thing about
teenagers
they are like
so able to detect dishonesty and
hypocrisy like so much better than at
any point in life like better than kids
better than adults
and they really really respect honesty
like they really respect it and so
sometimes if I'm doing an intake with a
kid who's in my office because they've
gotten themselves in trouble with
drinking or something like that
I will say are you worried about your
drinking like that's usually how I'll
start by asking
and sometimes kids will say actually yes
you know and then we're off to one
conversation
and sometimes they'll say
no or I don't know and I will say I
don't know yet how I feel about your
drinking I'm just gonna keep you posted
but based on what you're telling me I'm
not so sure
that this is working for you or that
this is safe what you're describing and
I'm Amazed by how accepting they are of
that like they would so much rather you
play your cards face up even if they
don't like your cards then have it seem
like you're bluffing hmm
yeah I mean I think the the the [__]
detector is super finely tuned you know
at that age
and uh is very strategically and
effectively weaponized against the
parent at just the right time like you
know what I mean like they know exit
because no parents perfect right and and
teenagers are paying attention and they
know a lot more about how you who you
are and how you behave than you might
realize
and uh you know don't don't don't uh you
know people in glass houses shouldn't
throw stones and so when you know the
parent comes down on the teen don't be
surprised when the Barb that comes back
is just you know absolutely Savage yeah
and and dead on that's what makes it in
the most honest and like insightful way
yeah to your knees it can be it'll be
brutal and I have in myself I'm
compulsively honest like I just like
okay and I think that's why I like
teenagers because I feel like if I'm
doing right by them like if if if they
feel like I'm
I'm all right by them then I feel like
that I must be right on the right that's
like that's a very insightful thing to
understand I think yeah no they have
very high standards um and you can lose
their faith quickly
um but it was interesting I I was at a
school where I was asking
kids what they wanted me to tell my
their parents when I met with their
parents later in the evening and
they said all sorts of things that I
thought were fair and I was writing them
down and one kid said could you tell my
parents to please remove all the screen
time restrictions and I said yeah I'm
not doing that and she was like okay
like she would have really thought
blessed me if I was like yeah
I gave it a shot yeah I was like right
and she's like okay right and and so I I
encourage people to just play their
cards face up with teenagers
one final thing I wanted to ask you
about the covet stuff before we move off
of that completely
um is something I've noticed around
uh just how uh uh teens are are kind of
processing and dealing with a low-grade
kind of chronic fear like if kova did
anything it kind of taught young people
like the world's a scary place you
should be afraid there's this invisible
thing out there that might harm you and
you need to wear masks or stay at home
or stay away from people and then on top
of that you know policy decisions that
were controversial and you know maybe we
can't trust adults to do the right thing
and it creates a very insecure kind of
unstable perspective of the world as
your mind is developing and that kind of
um
uh you know residue of that I think
still persists like you know there are
kids who even now it seems relatively
safer you know like but they insist on
wearing masks when they're outdoors and
things like that I was like what is
going on like yeah you know this is like
not a healthy you know way to kind of
navigate the world thinking that a
terrible thing could happen at any
moment and we should all be very afraid
all the time like that has to be the
mentality that would drive that kind of
behavior
yeah I
I mean I really don't know that we
wrapped our heads around how the
pandemic rocked us
and I think actually for a lot of people
it was a real loss of Innocence you know
around like how the world operates and I
I mean I think so so you know if we
think back to like I'd place it around
March 13th 14th of 2020 when you were
living your life one way one day and
then completely upended the next
so I think it has Jarred teenagers and I
think
um
there are kids who
started to use avoidance and withdrawal
as a way to manage that distress and
that stock and then that can happen
avoidance feeds anxiety the more you
avoid what you fear the more you become
afraid of it and continue to avoid
but I think there's also something even
bigger than that which is
teenagers like they follow the news
and unfortunately for them and for all
of us the news is with us now all day
every day
and they think about things like climate
change they think about gun violence a
lot there are a lot of kids who are
really anxious every day in school
because of yours around Gardens
um and and I know there's questions
about like this mental health concern
you know Rising mental health concerns
we're seeing and is it the sort of the
times and if is it made and people will
say well but there was like you know we
grew up in the Cold War where there was
always this sense of like you know
possible nuclear war and then there was
the World War II before that and I think
and so people will dismiss the kind of
you know do me explanation for why
teenagers are distressed but I think
like okay but when I was a teenager the
cold war came to mind every once in a
while right if I happen to read a paper
about it catch a new it wasn't someone
that the day after oh that was horrible
it was the worst I would never forget
that but okay so that was a single
exposure to Media about it and like the
jarring impact it had on us right
whereas kids now are all day long all
day long day all day long when I say to
teenagers here's what you need to
understand
about why this is so stressful for you I
said it used to be that there was the
morning paper in the evening news and
nothing in between and they can't even
believe it and and what a gift that was
too so I think that there's both the
jarring reality of having a virus upend
Our Lives which is not something any of
us I mean we knew theoretically but like
it was like Hollywood movie it wasn't
real thing but I also think we have to
acknowledge that
there are very frightening things that
teenagers I think in particular feel
saddled with like School violence and
also the climate
crisis as it unfolds that they also are
confronted with a lot in a given day
yeah it is a lot and it's the persistent
nature of it yeah like it's just
dripping into their awareness constantly
all day long and they're fed by
algorithms that are that are you know
prioritizing
stream hits like that yeah yeah it's
it's um
so what do we do so
part of what I think is
there have to be parameters around how
much
kids have their phones right and so this
is why I love not having them in
bedrooms if you can set that up
why I love it when kids are busy not
over scheduled but busy you know doing
stuff that just has them engaged has
them in theater groups has them in
sports has them making things has them
helping in the community
we're not getting rid of technology in
kids lives
I think the goal so much in parenting is
to make sure that it doesn't dominate
a kid's day
one of the things that that uh that I
loved that you initially ask
um a kid who comes into your office is
how you're sleeping yeah it's like yeah
before we even do anything or talk about
anything like what does your self-care
look like like are you even able to you
know be present with me because you're
not are you overlooking like one of the
most fundamental things about just being
okay in your body yeah no it's one
I'm almost hesitant to talk about sleep
because I think everybody knows it we've
all heard it we know we're supposed to
do it and yet the data on it are so
ridiculously clear about it being the
glue that holds us together
and
in that story in the book you know it's
about a kid who's best best friend has
been killed in an accident the kid is
devastated of course and there's going
to be a lot of work to do to help him
through
but I have learned clinically that when
people are in crisis especially I will
start with a question of sleep
and if they're sleeping we will get down
to work on working through the crisis
and if they're not sleeping I will get
down to work on figuring out how to help
them sleep so that we even have a chance
of getting them through
and I think that um this is something
that
we underestimate
and one of the questions that I comes up
a lot now is like what about kids where
they can't get care like they actually
need care and they can't get care
and it's getting better but it's still
not great and part of what contributed
to the Adolescent Mental Health crisis
was both the surge in need
and the reality that caring for
teenagers is a highly specialized field
very few of us do it and it's basically
impossible to scale up the workforce and
so the two together made for a really
tough situation for teenagers
so there have been a lot of teenagers on
wait list there still are a lot of
teenagers on waitlists
and what I'll say to parents is look
it's not a substitute for therapy but
make sure your kid is sleeping make sure
your kid is physically active make sure
they're eating well enough have them do
purposeful things put them in positions
where they're doing service or
activities these things
don't take the place of a really good
clinician doing really good work but
they go very very far often in both
reducing mental health concerns and
certainly in helping to prevent them
it's the low-hanging fruit I mean if I'm
not sleeping or I'm not exercising or
eating right or hydrating or doing any
number of those things I'm gonna feel
depressed and like [__] absolutely so we
can go down a therapeutic rabbit hole
but like fundamentally like if you
correct those things
I'm not saying it's going to solve
somebody's you know Mental Health crisis
but at least it will get you to some
kind of Baseline so you know what you're
dealing with absolutely absolutely and
what I love about that is first of all
we know it's true like the data are so
clear and second of all it is what
parents can do at home their parents
don't have to feel helpless when their
kid is suffering
it's hard when the phone's in the
bedroom though yeah I know okay so let's
let's put this on let's put this head on
yeah if you're like but my kid already
has the phone in the room I gotta get it
out like what can you try let me give
you some suggestions no over promising
here but some suggestions
I think first of all none of us should
have our phones in our rooms I don't
have my phone in my room and so one
thing a parent might do is to say okay
we're making a family-wide rule like
it's all coming out for all of us and of
course the teenager will be like no no
no no no and the parent might consider
saying look it's bad for our sleep it's
bad for your sleep sleep is the glue
that holds us together
for us to take it out of our room and
not ask you to do the same it would be
like we got in the car and we put on our
seat belts but we don't ask you to put
on yours so you can make that case
the other thing to try and again does
that work well I'm offering these
humbling I'm offering because I actually
it means enough to me that I don't want
to just write it off yeah yeah I think
the other thing to try is to say let's
just do
a two to three week experiment like
sometimes teenagers will agree to an
experiment like let's take it out of
your room for a couple weeks and here's
a clock radio to replace all of the
things that you feel that it does
and then see if after a couple weeks
there's not some agreement around this
here's the other thing teenagers like to
know the why and this is again back to
the [__] detector like they'd like
to know the why here's the why
because I said so no that doesn't work
that will work no it'll work up to age
10. but now we're talking teenagers
right so here's the why we have data
showing that you do not actually get as
good as sleep in a room with technology
in it and the reason for this that the
researcher surmise and I think this is
true
is that we are all soap pavlovingly
pavlovianly attached to our devices
that
if they are present
we are deploying a degree of energy to
not engage with them
and I I have such a vivid memory of
having becoming aware of this when my
one of my daughters was in a preschool
well they were both in this preschool I
don't remember which kid it was we're
part of the weighed in for the preschool
was there was a period of time where the
parent was in the room with the child
but you know kind of reading quietly in
a corner
and I would have my phone with me almost
all the time I knew it was tacky to look
at it so I wouldn't look at it but I
could feel myself resisting the impulse
and one day I left it in the car by
accident
and I remember sitting in the room with
her and being aware of how like how much
more deeply present I was in the room
because I had no option of touching my
phone right so it removes that decision
fatigue yep and so researchers think
that even while we are sleeping if there
is a nearby phone a piece of our energy
is being deployed on not engaging with
that thing and so we do not sleep as
well
that's equal parts depressing that we're
we have a lizard brain like that uh and
uh
also alarming I mean it's a it's a
testament on just how powerful they are
right yep
um that's crazy well that's good advice
uh I want to talk a little bit about
dating being a dad I love that you
address this in the book
um
you know of course I'm a dad uh it's
to my mind a little bit
confusing about how to be a dad today
because cultural mores have shifted
quite a bit so the model of like you
know the generation that preceded us
like what my dad you know embodied as a
father figure
is now very different in terms of like
expectations you have to be you know
it's you don't have to be the provider
but there's sort of a you know I'm going
to provide for my family and I'm going
to be the head of household and I have
to be you know strong and firm but I
also have to be emotionally available
and have to be able to go to all the
school activities a Tuesday at one
o'clock in the afternoon and it feels
like you you kind of have to be all
things all the time all at once
um which you know as somebody I talked
to a lot of dads and I think there's a
lot of dads who are confused about how
to fulfill all of those buckets
and Be an Effective dad to a teenager
yeah
well
it's interesting because on the one hand
I hate
the sense of anyone feeling so spread
thin right or having such a sense of
like so much all at once and and a
really um strong sense of obligation to
try to meet it all and and be so good at
it
on the other hand a way we could turn
this a little
is like how wonderful that dads are now
Under the Umbrella of also being in the
nurturing role you know how sad that
there was a period where dads were out
were not included in that tent you know
of being a nurturer within the family
and what I would say is again our kids
are not in the house that long
it's short it's really short and
I I have a pretty high tolerance for the
idea that in the 18 years or so that
they're living in our homes
we're going to be spread pretty thin
and
it's easier I think to tolerate that if
you're like this is really time limited
like I'm not doing this this long
and then if there's a day where any
parent
of any gender is feeling like I didn't
bring my A-game at every single thing
what I would say is
warmth and structure
those are the two things we're trying to
provide
I don't think you can get an A plus on
both on any day because often you're
doing one or the other they're trading
off against each other a little bit
so if you can go for like a b b average
B minus average B plus average like on
your warmth and on your structure your
ability to be present and engaged in a
loving way with your kids your ability
to help create a predictable environment
kids will do the rest like I I think one
of the coolest things about my job
is that
sometimes I will
in school consultation work I'll know a
kid for a long time and then I'll meet
the parent and I'll be like wow this kid
is doing so well in light of who these
parents are right that's a recurring
theme in the book too it's like you meet
with the kid and the parents are all
freaked out and you're like actually the
kids got this dialed and like you people
are the ones who need to get your [__]
together a little bit sometimes and so
what I hope parents take away from that
is like a sense of reassurance of like
really like kids Bend towards Health
kids are often fundamentally adaptive or
if they're not getting it at home they
will get it somewhere right I mean so
many of us thrived in homes where life
at home wasn't what it was supposed to
be but we found fabulous teachers or
fabulous mentors so
I know for sure that guilt does not
improve parenting and fear does not
improve parenting
and so if
those of us who are raising teenagers
can try to keep those two things under
control we'll just do a better job
I think I'm like I have an inner teen
because I do the best that I can as a
dad and then I misstep and I [__] and
like oh I didn't handle that great and
then I go on Instagram and I scroll
through and I you know and I see like
there's a lot of super dads in my feed
who are you know who who post reels of
them being amazing dads doing amazing
things and then I feel like [__] I feel
like terrible
and I'm like I'm doing the thing that
I'm like in my you know I'm like trying
to get my team to stop doing you know
I'm no better than any any none of us
are okay but so then again like
comparing myself what a great way then
to have a conversation with a teenager
about it right that we're not above the
exact same thing that we're wishing they
would do less of right and that's how
you actually have an effective
conversation with them
um
I I
talk about this in the book like having
a conversation with a group of teenagers
where I was like oh man you know my
relationship with social media like it's
like a slot machine like I'll go on and
sometimes like I get lucky and I find
something that makes me happy and
sometimes I go on and there's something
that makes me miserable or often I go on
and like I'm just scrolling and
scrolling and I don't want to know what
I'm looking for and I'm not finding it
and I'm wasting time
I find those conversations with
teenagers are the most fruitful
conversations with teenagers because we
are bearing the reality that
we all struggle to manage these
Technologies well and then you can
actually have a real conversation yeah
um I liked how
in the book you kind of address trying
to establish
parody between parents in terms of
emotional emotional availability right
like this idea that you know one A kid
will like pivot to one parent like this
is the person that I can open up to but
I can't to the other person
um and then that creates all kinds of
like communication confusion and
uh it's sort of destabilizing and and I
know that like you know that it's
there's something there's going to be
natural aspects to that but as a dad
like trying to make sure that my kid
knows that I'm available for that and
and trying to find ways of you know
getting in so that they feel safe
talking to me just as much as they would
their mom and not always being
successful at that but that was helpful
good I mean you know there's always
division of labor in families that's
okay
um what I was
kind of new to me in the research as I
was working on the book was especially
in what you're describing about the
importance of dads being available to
boys to talk about feelings and you know
we know that boys are socialized to not
talk about emotion as much as girls are
and we know that that comes at a cost to
them and one of the things that came
clear as I was working on the book is
that for a lot of boys especially around
like middle school as they're starting
to consolidate a sense of masculinity
a lot of them decide that talking about
feelings is a girl thing to do and then
say they're in a two-parent heterosexual
home say it's only ever the mom who's
actually talking about feelings
and trying to have conversations with
her son about feelings
it's so well-meaning but it actually can
reinforce exactly what the boy believes
like see look right it's a girl thing
and so as I was thinking through like
how do we help boys develop emotional
fluency really really like the men in
their lives whether it's Dad or teacher
coach you know any variety of men need
to be the ones talking about their own
emotional experiences and then asking
boys about theirs if we are going to
work against this stereotype that
feelings are for girls
that's such a powerful Point yeah I I
stumbled upon it like I really had not
thought about it until I sat down to
work on this book yeah the other the
other kind of amazing thing that jumped
out to me about boys was around your
discussion relating to how girls sort of
mature uh more quickly like two years
Beyond boys at a certain you know stage
of of adolescence but then you have
these people in the same classroom and
boys being competitive and then just
getting trounced by girls because
they're more developed than the boys and
then what that does to boys self-esteem
you know kind of telling them that they
can't measure up to these girls and then
their inability to communicate their
emotions and their feelings particularly
to a male role model and you know what
is that you know how does that bear
fruit later in life yeah no I am that
was a really interesting section of the
book to write because I was looking at
the data and I'm also looking at the
phenomenology of kids I care for and I'm
like look at this like sixth seventh
grade because of the two-year jump on
puberty
girls are crushing boys academically
because they have a neurological
advantage
but on top of that and we don't talk
about this very much they're also taller
stronger faster
for the most part like just on average
and so these poor like like I really I
feel like I could have called the
section like it's really hard to be a
sixth grade boy right I mean because
they're getting
beat at recess
and then they come back into the
building and they're getting beat in the
classroom and you know it levels out it
changes over time but in that juncture
it's really hard to be a sixth grade boy
and of course the girls are developing
and it's also the exact same moment
where we see sexual harassment begin in
schools and so I thought like well this
is really interesting because I could
absolutely understand why a sixth grade
boy who's getting it coming and going
and made to feel small and feeling
competitive and wanting to consolidate a
sense of masculinity
might feel like well one route to that
is I'm gonna take these girls down a few
of pegs you know and comment in bullying
ways that are sexualized
and
the thing that was so interesting about
writing that section I was like how has
nobody said this before like I can't be
the first person and so right and
understanding that behavior doesn't
doesn't mean that that's okay like that
you know and it that's like the seed of
misogyny right then and there like in a
very patent obvious way it's almost like
those those group that those two groups
shouldn't be like in the same classroom
being educated in the same place at the
same time it raises that question to be
short
but if we're not going to go if that's
not the route what we need to do and
this is the suggestion I make in the
book is we've got to make sure that
these six great guys seventh grade guys
especially who might be smaller you know
just not on the front edge of puberty
have ways to feel good about themselves
right that they we cannot just hope that
they handle it well right that we we
need to find ways to put self-esteem in
place and another cardinal rule in
Psychology is self-esteem does not come
from people telling you that you're good
it comes from doing things that you feel
good about and so there are things we
can provide to Middle School boys that
you know where they can have meaning and
they can have Mastery that I would like
to think might keep them from taking in
a wrong turn as they're trying to find
ways to keep their self-esteem intact
yeah and just more broadly that idea of
a parent like telling their kid like
they're okay or they're doing good
again a well-intentioned thing but not
as effective as making sure that their
kid is being put in positions that are
challenging not too challenging where
they have to toil and struggle a little
bit and learn get to the other side of
it that's what builds true self-esteem
not the affirmations of the parents who
want to you know put a medal around
every kid's neck and tell them that
they're the most special thing in the
world yeah yeah no I I agree completely
and I again back to kids [__]
detectors I mean I think in some ways it
can feel like an insult if the kid knows
they did nothing and and people are
celebrating
the the final thing I want to explore
with you before I let you go is uh
is this very interesting uh era that we
find ourselves in
um around uh gender as you call it
expansiveness right like it does seem
you know like I'm an old fuddy duddy uh
that we're in a in a period of time in
which
um gender fluidity is you know something
that that is suddenly if not ubiquitous
is certainly uh a mainstream thing and
more and more young people are
identifying in new and unique ways uh
and you know there's a culture War
raging around all of this and I think
it's disorienting for parents to try to
understand it perhaps more disorienting
for for young people but it's certainly
a fascinating phenomenon that is
unprecedented at least you know in our
lifetimes like I haven't seen this and
so I'm curious about like is this
something that's always been there but
just there hasn't been a culture
permissive enough to allow people to be
comfortable expressing themselves in
this way is this something different is
what's driving this
um
help me make sense of yeah what's going
on I don't know that I have answers I
mean those are big questions that I
think it's also new it's all happened so
fast I think we're trying to make sense
of it
um
I could tell you what I would watch out
for though which is a single explanation
or anyone who wants to make it simple
right I think there's probably a lot of
forces at work that are changing this
landscape
um and it is you are right I mean
there's an incredible
polarization around it
um there's a lot of you know very very
vehement disagreement about how it
should be addressed how individual
families should address it what laws and
policies should be around it
um
as I watch the controversies around it
unfold with people having very strong
opinions like about whether we should
you know how we should respond when a
young person expresses that the gender
they were assigned at Birth doesn't feel
like the one that's right for them
what I always fall back on
is
how we think as clinicians which is
there's nowhere in the care of young
people
when a young person comes up against a
difficulty in the world or not fitting
in the world
in a particular way that they you know
been assigned there's nowhere that we
feel that there's a single solution that
is going to be right for every kid so
whether we're talking diagnostic stuff
like even something as comparatively
simple as ADHD right
and not that gender expansiveness is a
disorder but just thinking in terms of
like when clinicians are called in to
try to help somebody through something
you should go run screaming from the
hills any clinician who's like there is
one way we do this we do this every way
for every single kid
so what I think
as a clinician is you know for every kid
and family going through this
they deserve what we would give
every kid what we should give every kid
for any concern that arises which is a
very careful consideration of the
specific circumstances of that child
that family the forces around them the
resources available to them
psychologically and otherwise
should be married with clinical
experience clinical understanding to try
to figure out
what the path is most likely to be you
know most useful path for that
particular young person and so as I hear
these controversies unfold I feel like
anyone who tells you there's one way
this should go down
I wouldn't
trust that about transgender
expansiveness or anything I'm not a kid
and then that's how I try to think about
it clinically yeah I mean there's
there's you know policy disagreements
about gender affirming care and there's
legislation around you know this sort of
thing and then there's the whole debate
around trans participation in sports and
all of that that's one thing but then
there's just the case of the kid who
raises his or her or their hand one day
and says hey you know I want to be this
and I want to be called this and and the
parent trying to understand that you
know every parent wants their child to
be happy uh you know hopefully that
child will be received with compassion
and empathy and and a real you know true
honest desire to understand and in the
appropriate case you know uh you know
therapeutic protocols can get introduced
someone like yourself but I still think
even with all of that like from and I'm
I'm asking you from the perspective of a
parent like how does the parent you know
really uh you know show up for a kid
like that
um with the kind of competing concerns
of like compassion understanding love
Etc you want the best for your child and
like what is the responsible choice here
particularly in the case of a child
who's pushing for for medical
intervention
Etc you know like then it becomes like
very real very quickly and and because I
think there are a lot of people who are
kind of contending with this right now
um there's a lot of you know confusion
about like how to how to really you know
walk this path yeah
so there's
a simple answer that is
which is we do have data showing
that for parents to take an affirming
stance
will be the thing that most protects
that child's Mental Health
so what you're talking about being
compassionate and attentive
that the data bear out like in terms of
protecting the mental health of that
young person
that is the response that parents can
bring that will make the biggest
difference
then the question of affirming right can
then start to go into very complex
territory about what that means and
especially when we're talking medical
interventions
and what I wish every parent had access
to but they don't
is you know we have university-based
clinics where there are experts who have
seen this may be your first gender
expansive kid they've seen hundreds of
gender expansive kids and the value of a
good clinician is that they have a lot
of information to work with in terms of
making recommendations and they can see
your child against a backdrop of a lot
of kids and a lot of outcomes and
trajectories over time
and offer some wisdom to parents about
how this may likely unfold or what the
options are or what the you know
complexities are so what I would say is
in the immediate
if we go by the data and we go by what
protects kids mental health parents want
to be supportive
in the um
difficult details of what that looks
like I would never want parents to feel
alone or that they have to figure this
out from scratch or they would have to
figure this out
without the wisdom of people who spend a
lot of time thinking about this and have
worked with a lot of families through
similar situations
are there resources or websites for
parents who find themselves in that
situation that are helpful I think or
I've got some resources that I mentioned
in the back of the book around
texts that are done I myself am a big
fan of university-based clinics you know
the nice thing about universities is
that they tend to be very very up to
date on Research they tend to bring a
very decent balance to their
consideration of anything so you know I
would say that you know for a lot of
things you know you want to be where
they are training people and so as a
function of training people they are
staying very much on top of what's going
on
so what I would say is
for a parent in this position if they
can access a university-based resource
center that will usually be the most
reliable and the most current
body of wisdom yeah that's helpful
thanks
um
as we round this out I I guess the final
you know question that I would have for
you
with all of the kids that you that you
treat and you know the many years that
you've been in this and all the school
you go and you speak all the time at
these schools you're interfacing with
parents and young people uh
what do you think are the the
low-hanging fruit of like parental
mistakes like the things you just see
all the time and you're like
haven't we gone through this like come
on like what you know what's the like
the one thing that you wish parents like
if they were to take away one thing from
this conversation like stop doing that
or maybe do a little more of this
I'm so glad you're asking here's what I
would say
when kids come our way to tell us they
are upset which they often do teenagers
especially talkers are good at this
overwhelmingly all they want and all
they need is for us to listen and be
empathic
in response for us to really tune in the
way I I try to do this as a parent is if
one of my daughters is telling me she's
upset about something I'll picture she's
a reporter and I'm her editor and she's
reading me the article of her distress
and that when she gets to the end of the
article I just have to produce the
headline like I have to have listened so
intently that I can distill it and
summarize it and add nothing and give it
back to her
so really all they want is that level of
listening and then truly rich like the
number one thing I say in my home more
than anything is like oh man that stinks
right just just sitting and empathizing
in response
that is overwhelmingly what teenagers
are looking for
and so often and I do this too what they
get instead is advice like they tell us
what's wrong and we're like well you
know and
um
I one of my younger daughter said to me
she said Mom I can tell from the look on
your face when I'm talking to you when
you stop listening you've come up with
the thing you're going to say to me by
way of advice and you're now just
waiting for me to pause right right
you're just like okay let me just wait
until this is over and then I'm gonna
I'm gonna throw the Zinger drop some
wisdom on you so so what I would say is
it's very rarely what they're looking
for or what they want or need and it
usually actually
um ruins a moment that could be going
quite a bit better so curiosity plus
empathy or just empathy is I would say
overwhelmingly the most effective and
also wanted response when teenagers come
our way with their distress beautiful
I love it
um you are a gift I think the work
you're doing is so important and I
really appreciate you coming here today
to
share your wisdom and experience you are
the Teen Whisperer such an honor such an
honor to be here and with you thank you
um Everybody pick up the emotional lives
of teenagers also uh Lisa has a podcast
ask Lisa yep the psychology of parenting
and what's great about that is that it's
subject specific so if you're a parent
and you're like God damn it my kid did
this one thing or like this thing
happened I just don't know how to deal
with it you can scroll through her
catalog and chances are like it's a
question that's come up that she's
talked through and uh I have relied upon
this resource successfully so
um check that out and uh anything else
you want to point people to
um I have a website Dr lisademore.com
and what I've tried to do is design it
so that people can really find the
resources they're looking for I have it
in six sections and for every section
there are articles podcasts TV work I've
done
um I want parents to feel like that
website is actually like a catalog of
utility for them yeah yeah that's great
and uh and you are here and help like
you spoke at a school this earlier today
you came here and now you have to go
back to that same school to like talk
again like this is what you do this is
what I do and it's I am so so fortunate
that this is what I get to do
um well you're always welcome here and
uh thank you again and best of luck and
if I can be of service to you and your
mission please let me know I really
appreciate it thank you cheers peace
[Music]